So A, we've been talking over the last several
weeks about just like the total havoc that's
been, uh, happening on the David Pakman show
youtube channel.
And we had the really great news earlier this
week of reaching 700,000 youtube subscribers.
I think we're now closer to 704,000 maybe
705.
And to catch you up there have sort of been
three primary issues that we're facing on
the youtube channel, which is just one of
our outlets, right?
We're on 200 radio and TV stations.
We've got an audio podcast that has been growing
significantly.
It has grown 40% since my appearance on the
Joe Rogan program, interestingly enough, and
that's been really great.
We've got the free speech TV broadcast of
the show on Directv and dish network and then
we've got youtube, which is a big piece of
what we do.
The three issues we've been been dealing with
are deep prioritization in youtube algorithm
in favor of corporate media.
What I mean by that is when you watch a video
on youtube, youtube recommends additional
videos to you and as I've detailed extensively,
I won't do it again today.
Don't worry.
Um, youtube has been increasingly suggesting
people watch corporate youtube channels like
CNN, MSNBC, the late night shows, produced
with, you know, tens or hundreds of millions
of dollars behind them, et cetera.
Rather than independent content like ours.
We've lost about 3 million views a month as
a result of that algorithmic change.
The other issue has been demonetization of
videos that should be earning money.
They don't violate any of youtube monetization
rules as they are written.
Although the devil seems to be in the interpretation
of those rules.
We will produce a video, research it, edit,
upload, all of that stuff and then a youtube
algorithm will determine it's not going to
run any ads.
Sorry, you don't get to make any money off
of this content you've spent all day creating
a, that's been issue number two and issue
number three, which is the one I've spoken
the least about is people reporting to me
that they have been subscribed for a long
time in many cases and then all of a sudden
they notice they're not seeing our videos
on their homepage anymore.
They specifically go to our channel and all
of a sudden they realize they're not even
subscribed.
We have not talked that much about it.
I have been telling you tube for months.
Every time I have a call with our youtube,
uh, rep, I say, or almost every time we are
continuing to get dozens of emails from people
who say, I'm, I'm not incompetent.
I know I was subscribed to your channel.
I am now unsubscribed.
And, uh, one of the unfortunate things is
that we just hit 700,000 subscribers who knows
where we would be, where this unsubscription
problem, not an issue.
And I finally got a video from a viewer of
this happening and you will notice that the
viewer, this is on Youtube Mobile app, uh,
similar activity has been told to me is taking
place on desktop of viewer, sent me a video
from mobile and you see him click onto our
channel.
And even though he thought he was subscribed,
he wasn't, he clicks the subscribe button,
it seems to work.
And as soon as he comes right back to our
channel, he has again been unsubscribed.
So this is only part one, like this is the
issue of subscribe isn't sticking and he immediately
noticed it.
The bigger issue might be people who have
been subscribed for a long time, they are
subscribed to a bunch of channels.
So they don't necessarily immediately notice
that they're not seeing our videos and their
subscription feed.
They come back to our channel when they think
about it and they realize, oh, I've been unsubscribed
from the David Pakman show and this has a
cumulative effect.
What I mean by that is subscriber growth creates
subscriber growth.
If you have a hundred people who are subscribed
and sharing your content, now everyone who
sees those hundred people's social media posts
about our content are more likely to become
subscribers themselves.
They are then likely to generate more subscribers
for us, so the value of one subscriber has
a sort of economic multiplier effect to use
an economic term.
If there are a thousand people unsubscribed,
that means there are a thousand of fewer people
sharing our content from which we would derive
even more subscribers in the future.
So this is depressing.
It's disappointing.
I can do nothing about it.
I've told Youtube about it probably 20 times.
If you have other videos like the one we showed
or other information, if you're noticing it's
happening in particular browsers, if you're
noticing it's happening on mobile and not
desktop or vice versa.
Any information you have, please get to me.
I don't have any reason to think right now
that this is malicious.
A lot of people report this.
I think it's a glitch that youtube simply
hasn't fixed because even though many people
tell them about it, rarely do we have examples
like this on video.
Now we have one.
Okay, so let me know if you have any more
light to shed on this problem.